[संगीत]
सो हेलो आप सभी लोग कैसे हो
अभी तक
थोड़ा सा जो लेक्चर है इंर्पोटेंस होने
वाला है इसके अंदर पहले का जो भी पड़ा है
अपने अभी तक तो सब कुछ कम आने वाला है सो
रिवीजन का मुझे लगता है नीड होगा
तो अपन इसके अंदर रिवीजन है वो लेक्चर के
साथ-साथ
चलो
बहुत एक इंपॉर्टेंट पार्ट है इसके आने
वाले हैं जो हर प्रोग्राम के अंदर आता ही
है और आना भी चाहिए
कौन सी चिड़िया का नाम है यादव
हरदी कांस्टेबल सिक्योरिटी की तरफ से
पाइथन का कैप्सूल कोर्स लेकर सो लेट को
हां तो इस कंडीशन क्या होती है ना
यह ऐसे अगर वैसा राहत है तो उसमें अपन
इस्तेमाल करते हैं ये अगर सब पे गौर करना
एक मतलब अगर
ल से मतलब कुछ भी नहीं मैं कुछ भी नहीं तो
यह तो यह ऐसा चीज चला है अपने पाइथन के
अंदर की अगर माला पर कोई कंडीशन लगाएंगे
क्योंकि यार भाई तो अगर 18 प्लस है तो
तेरे को ये करने का है भाई अगर तो पॉजिटिव
में है तो तेरे को यह करने का भाई तू बड़ा
है तो तेरे को यह गाने का है तो छोटा है
तो तेरे को ये गाने का एक कंडीशन लिखने का
अब नहीं कंडीशन जो चीज देना यार अपनी है
ना हर जगह कम आई है लाइफ में ले लो चाहे
वॉइस में ले लो चाहे अपने उसके अंदर ले लो
क्या कहते हैं अपना यही के अंदर ले लो हर
जगह पे कंडीशंस ग रहे हो तो कम आई ही आई
है ठीक है ना कॉलेज में ले लो तो मैं
गर्लफ्रेंड बकरी वह भी कंडीशन लगती होगी
यार ये करोगे तो मैं एक साथ जाऊंगी तो ये
नहीं तो नहीं
लगती है
प्रोग्रामिंग है क्या मतलब इतना भी तो
हार्ड वाला चीज है नहीं इसके अंदर मगर
सिर्फ रियल लाइफ कॉन्सेप्ट सी है जो अपन
ये कंप्यूटर में लगा रहे हैं और कुछ नहीं
है प्रोग्राम के अंदर तो ये कंडीशंस के
बड़े में समझेंगे
जैसे मतलब
<=
उन चीजों के बड़े में और वो सब कुछ ओपन है
कल जो ऑपरेटर पड़े थे ना कल का लेक्चर भी
एकदम रिवाइज करके आए हो ना गाइज तो फिर
तुमको ये वाला भी अच्छे से समझ में आएगा
कोई आए लिखेगा नहीं चाट में की ये एडवांस
ताकत के आए हो तो अगर फिर भी एडवांस
दे दिया है
तो फिर अपना थोड़ा सा अच्छा चलेगा
मुझे बता देना की अगर आपको ऐसा ग रहा है
क्या होते हैं
पब्लिक
यही रहते हैं यार ठीक है
आगे डिफरेंस देखेंगे अगेन आपको कौन सा उसे
करना है वो भी देख लेना और मोस्ट कॉमनली
लोग क्या उसे करते हैं वो भी आगे देखेंगे
तो डोंट वारी सब एकदम बढ़िया चलने वाला है
हां तो अपने कंट्रोल स्टेटमेंट क्या है
तो
इसको
कंटिन्यू चलती है
ही होता है कंटीन्यूअस में भी चाहिए होता
है ठीक है ना तो जैसे अपने अगर कहते हैं
की भाई ब्रेक ग गया मतलब थोड़ा ब्रेक ले
लेते हैं उसके बड़े में सब टूट ही जाता है
लूप्स के अंदर भी वही है ब्रेक लगाने के
बाद लुक तू उट ही जाता है ठीक है
कॉन्सेप्ट वही है इंप्लीमेंटेशन अलग है
ठीक है
है तो चलते हैं इस पे
तो अपन है
क्या देखा था की अपन जब अपने जब भी
ऑपरेट्स का इस्तेमाल किया था कंपैरिजन
ऑपरेटर वगैरा का जैसे यह प्रिंट
युटुब
मेरे को बताऊंगा अभी लिखने के बाद में
इसको बताता हूं मैं एक बार यह सिंबल जो भी
कहते हैं
ठीक है यह तो स्पेस
है अभी तो क्या किया ना मैंने इसके नीचे
इंटर मारा तो अपने बेटा स्पेस में दे दिया
है अगर कभी-कभी
इसके नीचे वाला कैकॉर्डिंग मतलब इस अगर ये
चीज हुआ उसके बाद में अपन को ये वाली लाइन
घंटी नहीं करनी है
ठीक है
ये इंडेंटेशन यह दर्शाता है बाकी पकाने
में लैंग्वेज के अंदर अपन क्या करते थे ना
जैसे मैंने यहां पे है ना इसको इसको करने
से लिख दिया इसको कंडीशन लिख दिया उसके
बाद में इसको ऐसे चालू करते थे ना ऐसे
करने के बाद इसके अंदर ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड लिखने
थे फिर ऐसे खत्म कर दिया करते थे जो ये
दशरथ था की इसके बाद अपन को ये कोड
कंटिन्यू करना है अगर आपने यहां जो लिखा
है वो ट्रू है या जो भी है
ठीक है ना जो आपने इस्तेमाल किया है या
फिर जो भी सवाल किया है उसके बाद में आपको
ये वाला ब्लॉक को फोल्ड रन करने का है तो
ये किसका पार्ट है ये किसका सब कोड है ये
अपना इंडेंटेशन बता रहा है पाइथन के कैसे
के अंदर अपन को ये कर ली ब्रैकेट वगैरा
लगाने की कोई नहीं ए पाएंगे
ठीक है
अब अगर मैं इसको प्रिंट अगर इसको मैं यहां
पर लिख दूंगा
ठीक है ना
तो देखो
20 है ये 30 हो गया
कोड में कहा है किसी गेट करो
और फिर जो ये ग्लोबल लिखा हुआ है इसके
अंदर तो ये इसने गिफ्ट कर दिया की हां भाई
अब तो ये ठीक है ये वाला नहीं है तो ये तो
अपना बड़ी लिखा हुआ है तो ये तो प्रिंट
करने का ही है
प्रिंट
के साथ में
ग गया है यह इसका है
यह
देखते हैं
ठीक है
और आप लोग को समझ में ए रहा रहेगा
भाई अपना तो अगर मैं इस कंडीशन को ऐसे भी
कर देता हूं देखना गैस ढंग से एक बार कोड
चेक करते रहना मैं कूद के चेंज करता हूं
तो इस दौरान कोड में चेक भी करते रहना अगर
छोटा दिखे रहा है तो यह बता दो की भाई
बहुत छोटा लिखा हुआ है यहां पर हम देख
नहीं का रहे हैं तो वो भी सर्विस ओपन कर
देंगे
ब्लॉक के अंदर नहीं है किसी के ब्लॉक नहीं
है
ये इसका ब्रोकर नहीं है ये खुद का ही कोड
है ये ठीक है ना तो ये वाला प्रिंट हो रहा
है
इस ग्रेटर
होगा|
तो उसे कैसे में अपन क्या करते हैं जब
अपने पास में मल्टीपल कंडीशंस आई है की
अगर दोनों इक्वल हो तो दिखाओगे बहुत अधिक
हो तो जब इस कैसे में क्या करते हैं ना
अपन यहां पर एक और कीवर्ड राहत है इसका
चेक करो
या तो सबको समझ में आया की नहीं
बता दो की आप लोग को समझ में ए रहा है की
नहीं अटेंडेंस तो वैसे ही बहुत कम हो रही
है आप लोगों की
अच्छी नहीं ग रही हो मेरी बट फिर भी कोई
बात नहीं अब जय लो गैस कितने दिन र गए
तीन दिन और र जाएंगे
सेवन डेज में भाई होगा
ये नहीं लेंगे अपन उसे कैसे में यूजर से
इनपुट लेंगे ठीक है ना
उसे कैसे में इनपुट लेंगे तो यूजर्स इनपुट
लेने के लिए तो मुझे बताया क्या करता है
तो क्या मैं क्या फंक्शन कल करूं
इनपुट ही लिखेंगे
बी
यहां पर बी का वैल्यू हो जाएगा
तो यह वाला थोड़ा ब्लॉक कर समझ में आया ना
सबको
यह क्या कर रहा है कैसे कर रहा है
यहां से इनपुट लगा स्ट्रिंग में उसको
कन्वर्ट करेंगे डीजे में उसे से होगा
ठीक है ना से बी के साथ भी होगा
बाकी चाट गुप्त तो है ही
अब मुझे कोई तीन नंबरों में से कोई एक
बड़ा नंबर पता करना है
ठीक है तो उसे कैसे में मैं एक लॉजिकल
ऑपरेटर का इस्तेमाल करूंगा तो मैं भी
तुमको ये भी बताऊंगा की इसमें अपन लॉजिकल
ऑपरेटर का इंप्लीमेंटेशन कैसे कर सकते हैं
वो इंप्लीमेंट हो कैसे रहा है उन सब चीजों
के बड़े में अवेलेबल बात करेंगे ठीक है तो
अभी मैं यूजर से इनपुट
लोगों की नहीं
तो बताओ उनकी बिना उसे इनपुट के बताओ
शायद कुछ लोगों को ऐसा लगे की थोड़ा हैवी
होगा ऐसा कुछ
क्या सीन है
ओके तो ऐसा कुछ नहीं भाई मैं खुद भी ऐसे
ही सोच रहा था बट मैं आप लोगों के र जाना
छह रहा था
जो एडवांस वाले हैं उनको तो क्या यह भी
मतलब यह भी कुछ इजी सा है
कैसे बनाएंगे
अगर हां और भी से बड़ा है तो लार्जेस्ट
नंबर हो गया अपना
ठीक है
बी ए
और सी से अपना बड़ा है अगर ए और सी से भी
बड़ा है तो अपना बिग लार्जेस्ट हो गया
ठीक है
तो फिर सबसे बड़ा ही होगा क्योंकि तीन
नंबर ही है
तो 20 अपन चेक करेंगे
लॉजिक बता दिया मैंने की लॉजिक कैसे निकले
कोई बता देना
ख्याल
30 लीटर दिखा रहा है इसके अंदर
अभी हुआ कैसे ना
एक कम करता हूं सॉरी
तो यह पूरे को फल से दे देगा
जल ए गया था मतलब ये पूरा जल दे ही देगा
तो यह भी जल हो गया बच्चा अपना ये तो ये
फिर ट्रू दे देगा मतलब कुछ नहीं हुआ तो
फिर मैंने कहा की अगर ये नहीं तो ये कुछ
भी नहीं तो यह
सॉरी
इजी पड़ेगा अगर हिंदी में देखा जाए तो
ऐसे अपन पता लगाते हैं की कौन सा दिन में
से कौन सा वाला बड़ा है ठीक है ना
[संगीत]
30-20
के दिखाएं
लोट के अलावा
उसके उसके बड़े में कोई लिखकर देगा मुझे
चाट के अंदर
एक बार रिपीट करने का है
वो मुझे चाट में लिख दो तब तक मैं इसको
रंग एक्सप्लेन
तो पहले का पेट्रोल
और साथ में चेक करें
उसके आगे पैठण का प्रोग्राम जाकर भी नहीं
ठीक है उसके परछाई भी नहीं आएगी
इसको एक बार प्रैक्टिकल करके देखोगे ना तो
ज्यादा समझ में आएगा
अभी क्लियर हुआ की नहीं
[संगीत]
सबसे ज्यादा क्लियर करो की क्या कहना
चाहते हो या फिर क्यों बड़ा होता है
तो अभी अपना यहां पर खत्म
राहत है उसके अंदर रहते हैं अब आगे भी
अपना ये फेल्स आएगा
सो अभी भी किसी के समझ में नहीं आया हो तो
स्पीड से चलें
भाई
टेंशन नहीं करो यार ज्यादा होगा तो एक और
दिन एक्स्ट्रा बड़ा देंगे यार मेरे से
एक्स्ट्रा पढ़ने में आपको दिक्कत है क्या
वो बाद में पूरे निभाए जाएंगे
जब तक अपना
स्मॉलर एट 10 से
तब तक यह लूप चलेगा
प्रिंट अपना आई
और और यह चीज तो हो गई
के अंदर वालुज एड करते रहेंगे
ठीक है
तो इसको मैं थोड़ा सा सिंपलीफाई कर देता
हूं इसको ओपन ऐसे भी लिख सकते हैं
पहले वाले जीरो था जीरो के अंदर एक और एड
कर दो फिर से कर दो
यह इसका मतलब होता है जो पिछले वाला आई है
उसके अंदर एक एड करो की कितना जा के से कर
दो
यहां पर फिर मैं आपको इस लूप की अच्छे से
और डिटेलिंग में वर्किंग बताऊंगा
अच्छे से
चलो ठीक है
तो जीरो ठीक है
कृष्णा का ट्रू है हां भाई मैं छोटा हूं
ऐसे तो उसमें आएगा पहले प्रिंट कर दिया
अपना आई जो था आपने जीरो
ठीक है
यह हो गया
है यहां
पर
सिंपल सा यहां पर
छोटा है
होने के बाद में इसे दिखा दिया यहां पर
अपना
था चिंटू
ठीक है
चलेंगे तो उसे चीज के बड़े में बात करें
तो वो ज्यादा बटर रहेगा
तो उनको भी अपन बताएंगे अभी
तो प्लीज वेट
तो यहां पर अपना क्या हुआ
यहां पर जो वन था अपना हो गया है तू तू
प्लस वन हो गया
ठीक है तो यह वाला तो ठीक था यह 3 अपने आप
पर ए गया
अपना क्या कहते हैं
तो भाई का नया वैल्यू क्या हो गया अपना
बताएंगे की क्या 55 से छोटा है
तो यह हो जाएगा
तो यहां अपना लुक
मैं भी कुछ टाइम और पकाऊंगा
ऐसे करके या मतलब दूसरों को कंफ्यूज मत
करो
यहां पर तो है तो ये कंडीशन
में सीधा ही ट्रू लिख दो तो अपने लैपटॉप
चला रहेगा चला रहेगा चला रहेगा
साथ में अपना एकदम स्लो हो जाएगा
ठीक है तो उसे कैसे में अपन को यह मोबाइल
का इस्तेमाल करते हैं
इतने मेरे को खुद को नहीं किसी ने बताया
मैं खुद ने एक दिन ऐसे ही मजे मजे में
ट्राई किया है वो क हो गया था तो
विल के साथ में भी अपना एस लगता है अगर
मैं यहां पे प्रिंट करता हूं अपना
डिजाइन
हो जाता है
बार-बार डायग्राम
तो यह अपना जाता है आगे बढ़ता है ठीक है
तो यहां पर जाकर एग्जिट हो जाएगा
थैंक यू
दोस्त लोग हैं जिन लोगों को मैं ऐसे सीखना
हूं उनके लिए पेन और आउट किया था तो उनसे
आदत पद गई है 6 महीना कॉलेज पढ़ने के बाद
मेरे से उम्मीद करते हैं की मैं इनको एक
महीने में पूरा 6 महीने का कर डन
मजबूरी थी
ठीक है
अपना आई
जीरो 1234
कर रहे थे एक दो तीन कर लाइन कर लाइन
के अंदर
कुछ अलग से कोड चलते हैं भाई देखो
सिंटेक्स अपना अलग होता है ठीक है
लेकिन लॉजिक अपना बिल्ड करना तो उसके बाद
में ना बाकी साड़ी चीज थोड़ी सी साल से
जाति है
आई इन रेंज
ठीक है ना
और इसके आगे एक और राहत है
जिसको ओपन बोलते हैं
जीरो में से अपन एक छोड़ के कम करना है
फिर एक और छोड़िए कम करना है वो अपन आगे
देखते हैं अभी मैं ये सुनने की कोशिश करता
हूं इसको मैं कैसे करूं आपको
एक-एक से बड़ा है ये अपने आप को एक-एक से
बढ़ेगा मतलब जीरो प्लस वन करेगा ठीक है तो
आगे हो जाएगा ये अपने वन हो जाएगा फिर वन
प्लस वन करेगा
थ्री हो जाएगा
भैंस के पास जाएगा
यहां पर सिलाई में से प्रिंट लुक चला फिर
फोर ए गया इमेज से प्रिंट लुक चला अभी ना
अगला ये क्या है की हां भाई खत्म हो गया
अपना इधर तक ही इधर तक कैमरा साथ था
यहां पर साथ छोड़ देंगे
तो स्टेप वैल्यू होती है
ना अभी तो एक-एक करके प्लस हो रहा था तू
कर दूंगा ना मैं अगर मैं इसको नॉर्मली
लिखना हूं यहां पे यहां पे वन लिखना हूं
मैं
तो ये एक-एक करके यहां पर ध्यान से गौर
करना ठीक है अब मैं इसको तू कर दूंगा मैं
यहां पर
तो देखो क्या हुआ ना जीरो प्लस तू कर दिया
इसने तो अपना ए गया तू तू प्लस
तू करके ए गया
अपना 8 प्लस
वैल्यू खत्म कर देगा
ठीक है ना
नहीं मतलब यह जो लिस्ट वाला करने वाला वो
नहीं उसके आगे का जस्ट मैं बताऊं की ये
चीज आप कर सकते हो वो चीज ठीक है
ना और जो पर है अपना इंटरवल चीजों पर कम
करता है ठीक है
तो मां लो अपना ये एक
ल नाम से मैं लिस्ट में राहत हूं यहां पर
लिस्ट चाहिए
तो हुआ
जाएगा
थ्री तो थ्री यहां पर फिर आगे हो गया अपना
लूप खत्म लूप क्या है की भाई को क्या नया
वैल्यू देने का है इसने आगे भी अगला
वैल्यू है तो अपना फोर दे दिया उसके बाद
में अपन फिर से इसके अंदर गए
प्रिंट कर दिया
फिर लूप खत्म
जो एक-एक करके आगे बढ़नी है
ज्यादा कम में लिया जाता है
ठीक है
मुझे पढ़ाई भी नहीं गया था यार
ठीक है अब है ना इस चीज को अपन एक लूप के
थ्रू भी मतलब अपने यह लूप के थ्रू अपन
इसको एक्सेस करेंगे बिना ये लिस्ट को
लगाएं लूप में इसका मतलब ये है की ये ल
इसके बगैर अपन उसे करेंगे लिस्ट की वैल्यू
उसको वो कैसे करेंगे यहां पर रेंज लिखेंगे
नहीं लिखने के बाद सबसे पहले क्या करेंगे
अपन की चालू होती है जीरो से जीरो चालू
होती है और अपन को चलना है तब तक जब तक
अपना यह ल का आखिरी वैल्यू तक है
लेंथ है कम तक चला है हमने अपना इंडेक्स
ठीक है ना
तो यहां पर क्या करेंगे
1234567 तो इसके लेंथ
चलेगा जीरो से लेक 6 तक चलेगा तो उसके
इंडेक्सिंग कैसे रहेगी
सिंपल
तो यह चलेगा
इस चीज को ऑटोमेटिक
जीरो वन तू थ्री फोर फाइव सिक्स तक जाएगा
ठीक है ना के बाद में क्या रहेगा की ल का
जो वैल्यू है वो बाद में प्रिंट होते
रहेगा
ये देखो ये ए गया
ठीक है
कम कर रहा है प्रिंस भाई
कम करता है
उनकी सिम अपन क्या करेंगे
चीज आपको हैवी ना लगे की यार इससे
एकदम धीरे-धीरे चल रहा हूं और मतलब अच्छे
से अच्छे तो आप लोग बताओगे अच्छे से चल
रहा हूं की नहीं बट मेरे हिसाब से थोड़ा
सही चल रहा होगा
अब मैं रेंज में करता हूं इसको
जीरो से लेकर 20 तक
कम करता हूं
अब मैं चाहता हूं
आई डबल इक्वल तू 10
ब्रेक
जैसे आया ना
अभी पहले रुक गया
तो पहले प्रिंट हो रहा है अब फिर चेक हो
रहा है इसलिए
ठीक है
मतलब जी वैल्यू को अगर अपन तू से डिवाइड
करेंगे
टेंथ क्लास तक की वेबसाइट पर कम आएगी अपनी
पुरी मस्त झकास एकदम
तो
डबल रिक्वेस्ट 20
अप्रैल
को डिवाइड करके
फूल मतलब
2 * 1 =
8 2 * 5 = 10 ठीक है ना
तो ऐसे हां तो ऐसे अपन चीजों को इसके अंदर
लूप के साथ में चलते हैं
ठीक है ना अब है ना अब मां लो की
एक तो मैंने विधायक आपको बताया ठीक है ना
अब अगर मैं चाहता हूं की यार
को यहां से स्किप
यहां पर जैसे ही यह अपने टाइम की इक्वल तो
इसमें आएगी भाई धूप को आगे कंटिन्यू कर दो
उसके आगे नीचे कोर्ट नहीं दिखेगा ये चीज
वो कोड था वो नहीं दिखेगा इस जगह कभी इसके
आगे का लोग आप कंटिन्यू करो मतलब इसके
नीचे जो था वो क्रिएट करना इसके आगे हम
लोग कंटिन्यू करो
ठीक है
भाई तुम अब इसके आगे आगे जो
स्किप कर दिया यहां पीछे देखते हैं अपन तो
पीछे है में के बाद में 10 ए रहा था
ठीक है ना पास कुछ कम नहीं करता पास मतलब
एकदम फालतू यह पता नहीं क्यों बनाया मुझे
भी समझ में नहीं आया बट ठीक है बनाया तो
बिल रिस्पेक्ट डेट और इसका फिर उसके तो
बता देता हूं अगर क्या है जैसे मां लो अगर
आपने कोई फंक्शन ऑप्शन बनाया या कुछ भी
आपने ऐसे ब्लॉक लिख के छोड़ दिया और आप
चाहते हो ब्लॉक की कोडिंग आप बाद में
करोगे ठीक है ना तो आप ये पास में कर देते
हो
ताकि इसकी कोडिंग का बाद में कर सुकून या
फिर आप बाद में इस चीज को देख लो पास से
कुछ जेली कम नहीं होता
भाई देखो अगर अपन को देखो किसी के नीचे
मतलब किसी के अंदर में किसी के साथ मदद
करेगा
ठीक है
एक ही ब्रेक को खुश हो जाता हूं
अगर मैं जाता हूं की
इच्छा पर भी
आई अपना
बड़ा
तो वहां पर ब्रेक लगा दो
तो देखो
आई जब तक
तो क्या रहेगा इसके अंदर की
जब आई 10 हो जाएगा तो ब्रेक कर दो
सिंपल यही मतलब है
और कैसे पता लगेगा की आई अपना टाइम हो गया
इसके अंदर अपन ने लिखा है
कंडीशन चेक करने के बाद में ब्रेक कर लेना
हां तो आज का सेशन हैवी
से लगा की कैसा था
की नहीं
जिसकी जो भी दिक्कत है
तो ऐसे ओपन चीजों को इस जो भी चीज
अपने-अपने की आप चीजों को मिलीमेंट कैसे
कर पाते हो और कुछ सीन नहीं है यह चीज
अपने मोबाइल के साथ भी करके देख सकते हैं
और विल के साथ भी रिवर्स वाला करके दिखा
देता हूं एक बार
मैं इनिशियल वैल्यू देता हूं अपना 20 ठीक
है एन वाइल्ड
[संगीत]
हां तो गैस आज का आप लोग को होमवर्क है जो
लोग कर रहे हैं वह लिख डॉग
यह पॉजिटिव
के बड़े में पता करो अपना
इन दो चिड़ियों के बड़े में खुद से पता
करो
पोस्ट में जान के बाद में यहां पर डेट 3
का है वैसे दे फोर का भी ए जाएगा ठीक है
ना स्क्रीन में कमेंट्स में जान का अंधे
जो कर चीज मैंने आपको होमवर्क के लिए बताई
है फिर से रिपीट कर रहा हूं आपको की अपना
ये जीरो से लेक 100 तक आपको वालुज में जो
फाइव शब्द सेवन दोनों से डिविजिबल है
उन दोनों उन दोनों के वो दोनों वो दोनों
जो फायर दोनों से कोई नंबर डिविजिबल है तो
वो नंबर आपको यहां पे प्रिंट करने का है
उसका प्रोग्राम है कॉपी पेस्ट करो या फिर
अपना स्क्रीनशॉट डालो कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
और उसके बाद में वोटिंग वोटिंग सिस्टम बना
ठीक है बताओ की आप वोट कर सकते हैं की
नहीं वह लॉजिक कैसे आपका वो बताना मैंने
बता दिया है पहले ही कैसा लॉजिक बनाने का
है ठीक है
नेगेटिव कोई नंबर नेगेटिव है ये पॉजिटिव
ये आपको पता लगाना है
लूप के बड़े में ये पता करना है ये ये कर
आपका बड़े-बड़े से तीन पे छोटे हैं एक
बड़ा सा टास्क है आपका
यह आपको टेलीग्राम चैनल के अंदर अगर आपको
कोई भी दिक्कत वगैरा है तो वहां आप डालो
वहां पे मैं जैसी आऊंगा मैं रिप्लाई कर
दूंगा नहीं तो फिर कोई भी वहां पे टीम के
बंदे आपको उसका रिप्लाई कर देंगे ज्यादा
बड़ा रहेगा तो मैं खुद ही वापस कर दूंगा
ठीक है और नहीं तो फिर अपना ये जो भी आप
ये टास्क कर रहे हो टास्क प्लीज यार कमेंट
में जाके समा कर दो पूरा टास्क मैंने कर
लिया है वो कर लिया है कैसे आपका फीडबैक
के वो यहां पर हमको बताओ या फिर टेलीग्राम
के अंदर बताओ हमको कहानी पर ही बताओ हर
जगह एक्सेप्टेड है ठीक है स्टोरी डालो
इंस्टाग्राम पे कुछ भी करो ठीक है तो आज
के लिए बस इतना ही और उसके बाद में आगे
अपन देखेंगे
आप फीडबैक अपना कमेंट्स में नीचे छोड़ दो
इससे भी वीडियो के नीचे आप अपने कमेंट
छोड़ दो आपको कैसा लगा अच्छा लगा तो लाइक
जैसा भी लगाओ ऑनेस्ट रिव्यूज आपके
एक्सेप्टेड है हमेशा बेकार रहेगा हम कुछ
बड़ा नहीं मानते हैं प्रूफ करने के लिए
बैठा है सो थैंक यू
जय हिंद वंदे मातरम